166 mille personnes inscrites ont voté
de jeudi à dimanche pour plébisciter un
candidat de gauche parmi les sept
présents l'ambition de cette primaire
populaire et de désigner la candidature
la plus apte à rassembler et faire
gagner la justice sociale l'écologie et
la démocratie
ce qui revient à proposer et soutenir un
unique candidat à gauche pour la
présidentielle
cette initiative portée par des citoyens
est fondée sur un socle commun de
valeurs qu construite avec plus de dix
partis n'ont eu élevé elle est fille et
le ps il reprend également des idées de
syndicats de gilet jaune de féministes
avec un fort ancrage environnementale
les inscrits devaient choisir parmi les
candidatures de la militante écologiste
à nags head porterie la socialiste anne
hidalgo le fondateur du parti nouvelle
donne pierre larrouturou yannick jadot
d'europe écologie les verts la militante
associative et ancienne adjointe à la
ville de rennes charlotte marchandises
la figure tutélaire des insoumis jean
luc mélenchon et christiane taubira
ancien ministre de la justice
première surprise d'autres candidats
historique de la gauche ont été écartés
comme le communiste fabien roussel car
il est pro nucléaires ou encore philippe
poutou du npa ou nathalie arthaud de
lutte ouvrière et trois personnalités
déjà candidate à l'élection
présidentielle figurent dans la primaire
mais contre leur gré yannick jadot jean
luc mélenchon et anne hidalgo le leader
insoumis ne mâche pas ses mots la
primaire populaire est une bande de
rigolos qui veut nous nuire même chaussé
yannick jadot qui qualifie cette
primaire de machine à perdre estime que
ses organisateurs se sont auto institué
en nouveau renouvellement de la pensée
politique mais justement qui sont ses
fondateurs la militante écologiste
mathilde himer l'une des initiatrices de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
de la campagne de la sphère du siècle et
des gis les citoyens ainsi que
l'entrepreneur social samuel grzybowski
fondateur de l'association inter
religieuse coexister fort du nombre
d'inscrits il estime que cette primaire
représente le plus gros processus de
départage de cette élection
présidentielle ce chiffre donne du poids
aux résultats du vote qui ne pourront
être ignorée par les différents
candidats et candidates cela rend
désormais crédible une dynamique de
rassemblement pour une victoire de la
justice sociale et de l'écologie en 2022
une initiative citoyenne d'ampleur qui
reflète le désir de démocratie
participative de très nombreux courants
de gauche ou apolitiques au delà des
partis mais cette démarche qui fait
émerger de nouvelles figures du milieu
associatif dynamite les partis en place
qui ne veulent pas céder du terrain et
qu'elle figure fera t-elle émerger peut
être simplement une candidature de plus
par exemple christiane taubira l'inversé
de la candidature unique à gauche de
l'union des gauches si fantasmer et
pourtant notre but n'est pas de diviser
mais bien de rassembler est il précisé
sur le site de la primaire et pour cela
toutes les tactiques sont bonnes à
déployer comme on peut le découvrir dans
une vidéo polémique de l'organisation
datant du 2 novembre dernier le porte
parole de la primaire populaire cm
grzybowski ainsi que les élus
conformément à un serment de romainville
adopté en octobre de bloquer leur
parrainage en attendant le résultat de
la primaire pour ne signer que le
gagnant ainsi il souhaite empêcher qu
anne hidalgo jean luc mélenchon fana
rosell et yannick jadot obtienne les 500
signatures avant la présidentielle il
exhorte eux-mêmes et bénévoles a
critiqué de plus en plus les candidats
sur les réseaux sociaux peser dans les
sondages pour qu'ils aient des
difficultés à contracter des prêts
bancaires des pressions très mal perçu
chez les candidats nous parle aussi de
la sensibilité politique de ses
organisateurs par exemple l'avocate
klara gérard rodriguez qui préside la
haute autorité de contrôle du vote de la
primaire elle a affiché sur les réseaux
sociaux sa sympathie pour l'ancien garde
des sceaux il ya quelques années
christiane taubira la secrétaire
générale du mouvement colline sert à
participer quant à elle il ya quelques
années à la campagne législative de
mounir majidi député la république en
marche au fil de ces révélations la
primaire populaire se fait dans certains
milieux taxé de lobby de la gauche de
droite quels que soient les résultats
c'est une première expérimentation de
démocratie participative à grande
échelle pour une élection en france mais
aussi une démarche qui a fortement
irrité les principaux candidats qui y
figurent une primaire bien trop décrié
pour être véritablement populaire